Hello, I'm Gav.
Welcome to the Slow Mo Guys.
You've joined me in the middle
of a Dallas wrecking yard.
For a long time, we've been a big fan
of these three blokes
so we're very excited
to be here to promote
season two of The Grand Tour.
Dan's late.
There he is!
What is that?
Check it out!
What do you think of this?
It's my RV.
You bought an RV?
Yeah.
Why?
Why, you know, I was thinking,
we shoot in these remote locations.
I want somewhere to chill
out like a home base.
Relax, have a shower.
Makes sense.
Bit of a road trip,
American dream and all that.
Absolutely.
Makes sense to me.
Yeah.
So you're saying you have a Grand Tour.
Right, yeah, Grand Tour.
So it'd be a crime not to
do something involving cars
and what looks good with
slow motion in cars?
Well, annihilating the hell out of them.
Smash them, yeah.
Any thoughts?
I was thinking, how about
a four-ton wrecking ball
and a huge crane usually used
to smash up massive buildings?
Yeah, so it should make
a sizable ding in a car.
I mean I think it's
slightly overcompensating
but anyway, we've got some old bangers
we're gonna annihilate.
And how about we test it on a wall first?
You gotta make sure you've
got a good wrecking ball.
Yeah, benchmark, yeah.
I agree.
Miley Cyrus, that's big!
Yeah, I wasn't messing around.
This is 9,000 pounds or
more than four metric tons
of pure heft.
Big old fat crane, swinging it in.
Yeah.
So we're gonna hit the wall from behind.
This is actually a real brick wall.
Solid, got some support on the back.
Obviously that'll be nothing
against this, though.
This is coming useful as a blast shield.
I'm gonna hug this as close as possible.
Yeah. The second use.
Triggering.
Oh, man!
Acted like it was nothing!
It just tore through it like a piece
of paper.
Just like Lego?
Yeah.
All right, so I think we're
ready to put the cars in.
Yeah, that was a good test.
We're ready.
Our victim, a real American car, isn't it?
Victim number one,
honkin' color!
It's like
what color is this?
It's like beige-y, tan, vom-y boke.
Definitely involves vomit somewhere.
It does.
A hundred percent.
So we're gonna absolutely
rail it just right there.
I think if we hit it low,
it's more likely to shift.
So we'll give it maximum beans
and get the hell out of the way.
There it goes!
Oh yeah.
Absolutely turn around,
it's coming, it's coming!
Oh!
That's a hit.
Just swept it right out frame.
It's like it just got a
broom and went like this.
with the car.
Look, it's buckled that tire.
Look at that!
Wait, what?
Do you see what's happened
is it's hit the rear
of the car, and this tire
has dug into the ground.
It pulled the tire off the wheel.
Yeah!
It ripped the tire
off the wheel and it's caused
the back of the car to go out
and this tire obviously didn't
have as much weight over it
so it span it around the back.
Oh!
Oh, man.
See now, here's your problem.
How are you gonna get in the car now
because the handle's broken?
How are you gonna pick up chicks?
I mean, you could drive it, sure.
But how are you gonna pick
up girls if you can't get in?
That is hefty.
Do you wanna see if the other door opens
and you can get into the driver's seat?
Yeah.
Oh!
It's like slightly
lower than it was before
'cause the wheel's bent.
Any idea how fast you can?
Look's like you've pranged it.
What happened here?
Well, funny story.
All right, let's have a
cheeky look at that footage,
shall we?
I'm up for it.
Oh, you know what, though?
Wrecking ball's absolutely fine.
Oh, wow.
You see the window go--
It's sort of, tablecloth
whips the window away.
Now, the car's just like,
moving from one place
to the other.
What's interesting is that even though
the area of impact is, you know, the size
of the front of the wrecking ball,
it drags in so much extra
material so the dent
is like, twice the size of it.
It's dragging door,
and it just bashed the
whole car out of frame.
See you later.
Look at that, you see,
see there, where the roof
now is becoming kinked
and being like, dragged down its crease.
It's flinging off all the paint.
Look.
Oh wow, that's so cool.
The paint's chipping off in those lines.
So there's an element of
difference to this car.
Oh, I see what you did with that one!
And the fact that there's no door pillar.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah.
The last one, we hit down here.
This one, if we raise
the ball, maybe a foot,
we'll get more sort of
crumplage in the top
and less moving of the whole car.
So we're gonna completely change the angle
of which you hit in the car,
so maybe just smash
through the top if you can.
Yeah.
All right, cool.
It's really, we don't ever really know
what's gonna happen.
We're learning all the time.
It's an experiment.
Do you think he ever
drops the ball on his job?
It's such a delay from this--
It really is.
Oh,
here it comes!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, man.
I thought that might happen
because we're hitting it
from the top.
I thought if the roof's strong enough,
it will flip the car.
Just straight in the window.
That's cool.
See the way the back glass burst?
Yeah.
That's wicked.
Look how it's like, almost pushing it
into the floor now,
dragging it along.
Way worse than being T-boned.
Look at that,
that glass is now just aerial glitter.
I like how the glass is
pretty much stationary
but the car is actually being shoved aside
faster than the glass is in the floor.
Yeah.
Oh, look at that
bend in the tires in the back there.
That's some pressure.
It's so impressive how strong the roof is,
the fact that it held on
and dragged it.
You wouldn't wanna have been in that one.
The mirror didn't even get touched.
It must have missed the
mirror by about an inch.
Oh there are some coins.
What, where?
Some pennies.
I need some change, actually.
Ah, you see, there's your problem.
What?
It's upside down.
It's on its side now, though.
It is.
Hard to move.
How are we gonna move it?
Should we?
Wrecking ball?
Wrecking ball.
It's like someone just punting it.
Yeah.
With a really big shoe.
There it goes!
Oh!
It did a 180!
Flipped it, I thought it was
just gonna go on its roof.
So it looks like one more
hit and it will be back
on its wheels!
Goodness sake!
Shockingly sturdy, the
underside of the car, isn't it?
Yeah, I mean, it's just
I think that's where
all the strength is, so,
the fact that it,
it just brushed off the wrecking ball
and all the force went
into flipping the car.
Oh!
Also, I think it's less sturdy on its side
than it is with the wheels on the floor.
So it's more--
More like, it's no longer bottom-heavy.
Yeah.
So that's some good swinging.
How do you feel about dropping?
I like dropping.
Let's do some dropping.
So we've hit the bottom of
one and we've hit the side.
Yeah.
Well now, we'll just
let gravity do the work
right on the front.
See, the idea is pull it all the way up,
push the emergency release, then drop it.
Basically just dropping the
equivalent of a small elephant
onto the bonnet, so yeah.
Yeah.
Like a female African Elephant.
All right,
very specific.
Let's do it.
Oh!
That,
well it just landed in the car.
It's parked in the car.
It's just parked in it.
You know what?
That hit the ground so
hard, it shook the camera.
Look at this, look at this camera shake.
What, like a giant--
whoa!
Like a giant's first
step, like in the films
when like, the dust moves.
If there was a cup of water on the floor,
it would have been T-Rex'ed--
Like Godzilla-style.
Look at this GoPro, it just sat there.
We could have killed that GoPro.
It's amazing it's alive.
9,000 pounds with a GoPro.
We'd do it.
Oh!
Look at how the,
the side window burst.
Oh, on the other side.
Yeah, on the other side.
It was there one second, the next second
it just burst.
It just exploded.
Excellent.
That went really deep in the car, there.
I'm convinced the wrecking ball
actually just hit the ground there.
Yeah.
I feel like we should
try and hit it again.
Try and hit it right here.
Thanks for that.
Sorry, straight onto the bonnet?
Yeah.
I mean, where's the steering wheel?
Uh.
It's in the seat.
Look at that.
The steering wheel would be in your legs.
Look!
It just popped out this.
It's just like
Oh!
That's the destruction we wanted, right?
Goodness, me!
Unbelievable.
Where is the engine?
Do you know when car makers say,
"Oh, we couldn't fit a bigger engine in?"
Yes, you could.
I don't think a window's
ever been more smashed.
You know, when they say you
take a brick to the window?
Yeah.
This is about the size
and width of the window.
The middle of it there,
where it actually landed,
it's turned all the glass back to sand.
Yeah, it's now powder.
It couldn't have been more
centered on the engine.
Perfect.
Whoa, that is destruction.
What you gotta remember is
there's an engine there.
There's like, there's a solid
chunk of metal in the way.
It's not mocking about.
It bounced off!
Yeah.
See that?
See the wrecking ball just rolling away.
Oh, that was a lovely
amount of destruction.
So satisfying.
We wrecked some cars.
Oh, it turns it into paper, doesn't it?
It's just like nothing was there.
I can see where it gets its name.
Yeah, yeah.
I love this wrecking ball.
Can we keep it?
How about we take it with us?
I mean, can you fly with a
9,000-pound ball of metal?
Imagine the excess baggage fees for that.
They'd just make you pay for
the whole flight, probably.
Just buy the plane.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to subscribe to the Slow Mo Guys
and make sure you check out new episodes
of The Grand Tour every
Friday with Amazon Prime.
We'll see you next time.
It's quite good, yeah?
Yeah, it was fun.
I enjoyed it.
What time is your flight?
I'm not flying.
Oh, you'll get there early.
Mine is pretty early.
I'm gonna go back to the hotel.
What, are you going back to the hotel now?
Oh no, I'm gonna have a shower.
Probably chill out for a bit.
You're gonna shower in the RV?
Hit the road, yeah.
Okay.
All right, well let me
know when you go back
to the hotel and I'll see you in a bit.
Sounds good.
Thousand frames.
Oh!
What happened?
Bloody hell!